مجموعه العسكريه الخاصه يقول بان وضع
روسيا حول مدينه بخمود بشرق اوكرانيا مهدد
ما لم تحصل القوات القوات التابعه على
الذخيره كيف نقرا هذه التصريحات
او بالاحرى الشكاوى
برهوج المؤسس مجموعه
اثار هناك نقص في الذخيره والامدادات ولكن
يوم مصدرت وزاره الدفاع الروسيه بيانا
النفق في تماما التاخير في تسليم المؤخائر
لكتائب المتطوعين دون الاشاره صراحه
لمجموعه باعتبار ان هناك مثلا على سبيل
المثال الحصر الكتائب التابعه لسلطات
اقاليم
دانيتسكو وايضا الكتاب الشيشانيه
افادت وزاره الدفاع الروسيه بانها تقوم
بتسليم المؤنث في الموعد المحدد وبدات
استعراض المؤن والبخائر التي تم بالفعل
تسليمها خلال الشهر الماضي نشرت الى انها
سلمت نحو 1700 قذيفه صاروخيه صواريخ وايضا
نحو 10000
و170 قذيفه
مدفعيه المدفعيه ذات العيار
الاسباب وراء هذه التصريحات ما الهدف منها
يبدو ان هذا البيان جاء بمعرض الرد على ما
تصريحات
للتاكيد على انه لا يوجد اي تاخير ولا
يوجد اي نقص لان هذا البيان نفسه اشاره
وبطرف خفيف ان هناك تقييم ايجابي لدور هذه
الكتائب التي تمكنت من تحقيق تقدم حول
مدينه مخلوط لا يزيد عن ثلاثه كيلومترات
بدعم كامل من المدفعيه الروسيه اي ان
الحديث يدور هنا عن ان دور الكتائب
المتطوعين ويقرا ما بين السطور اسمر ليس
هذا التقدم الواسع والكبير والذي بالفعل
يعاني من ازمات كبيره
واليوم ايضا شيبوه وقع او صادق على قائمه
بمعايير امداد كتائب المتطوعين بالمؤل
والذكاائر والاسلحه والمعدات والخدمات
الطبيه واشير في هذه الوثيقه الى انه سيتم
عامل معهم على قدم الوساء وساق مع مثل مثل
القوات الروسيه
تنافس بين الطرفين وربما يعني اختلاف ولكن
هناك محاوله من وزاره الدفاع للتاكيد بان
دوره دور القوات الروسيه والدور الاساسي
وان هذه المجموعات ليست اكثر من عوامل
المساعده بدلاله قيام وزير الدفاع الروسي
اليوم بزياره القوات بلاده في اوكرانيا
هناك ايضا انباء بزيارته لمدينه ماريوبولا
تفقد اعاده الاعمار ما الهدف من هذه
الزياره يعني بحسب العديد من الخبراء
المحللين بان هذه الزياره تركزت على محاور
ثلاثه اساسيه اولا متابعه عمليه
امداد القوات الروسيه بالدعم اللوجستي
وبالاسلحه والمؤن والبخائر وايضا متابعه
تدريب القتالي الوحدات الاحتياطيه التي
يتم في هذه المناطق بالاضافه طبعا لمتابعه
عمليات بناء البنيه التحتيه منها مجمع
عسكري ومركز طبي ومناطق سكنيه واخيرا
زياره مراكز القيادات الميدانيه حيث زار
شيبه الفعل مركز قياده مجموعه في جنوب
دانيت يربط المراقبون
هذه الزياره واستعدادات روسيا ربما لتوسيع
رقات المعارك على المستوى البري والدخول
لاراضي جديده لاستعاده السيطره عليها من
واخراجها من السيطره القوات الاوكرانيه
وبالتالي تقوم موسكو باعاده ترتيب اوراقها
والتاكد من توفر كافه الامكانيات للاقدام
على خطوه المعارك البريه التي في بدايه
الحرب يعني كانت يبدو انها الكثير من
النواقص شكرا لك من موسكو مراسل فرنسا